what's up guys how's it going we are
days away from the new iphone 7 being
released and i'm extremely excited i'm
still debating whether i'm gonna have to
sleep outside or not because as some of
you guys know by the time i actually got
my pre-order
my phone's not gonna be shipping for a
couple of weeks and then at that point i
wasn't able to even order a phone to get
day one it's a struggle and hopefully
i'll be able to get one to unbox for you
guys i keep seeing all of the questions
of how am i going to charge my phone and
listen to music and also i am going to
lose my air pods what do i do i just
recently saw an interview that tim cook
did and he said that the reason that
people end up losing their earbuds out
of their ears is because of the cord and
it's heavy and he said that he
personally has not
lost a single
air pod out of his ears since he's been
wearing them so tim
i believe you i will take your word on
it which it does kind of makes sense so
i am really excited to try those out and
they're not going to be ready i think
until october then he was talking about
how the case is just this little small
thing and they're magnetic so when you
drop the air pods into them they just
sort of suction down in and they charge
so that makes sense i'm still a little
concerned if i'm running and i'm going
to drop one out of my ear which i tape
them in my ear i'm not sure this little
solution here that a bunch of people
have been tweeting me is this spigen
spigen spidgeon
however you pronounce it it is a little
strap that you strap onto the air pods
and around your neck if you do drop one
it'll still be connected but this kind
of defeats the wireless purpose of them
here they are
just clips right onto the side here's an
image of them tied onto the side of the
airpod case
clipped to it
what do you guys think
i definitely think it'll keep you from
maybe losing them but then every time
you use them you're gonna have to end up
clipping that on there after they
it's just a lot of work i feel like just
to be able to listen to music and not
lose your headphones i'm ready for an
implant just put a bluetooth implant in
my ears let me hear music let it be
upgradable i'm ready take my body i'm
ready to be given up for science i mean
they're oh god they were originally
twenty dollars for this little tiny cord
at that point i could just tie a string
around them and put them around my neck
for free for the price of a string that
i find on the floor thankfully they got
the price to 9.99 i'll put a link in the
description if you want to check those
out next up is this belkin
lightning cable to two lightning cables
but
here's the thing is a lot of people are
going to be wanting to have a lightning
to lightning with a 3.5 millimeter jack
so that they're able to use their old
headphones so i'm not sure if this
really is the answer so basically what
this solution is for is people who have
the lightning cable headphones so you'll
be able to put the lightning cable
headphones in here and your lightning
cable here to charge so you'll be able
to do both of those with this adapter
which it says it's coming soon so
how soon because we need this now belkin
we need it now baby lightning cable
earpods earp wait your pods air pop
air pop the air pods or the air pods
they're not ear pods they're ear buds
lightning earbuds will come with the
iphone 7. here they are but they are
called ear buds earbuds air pods either
way this looks to be the solution to
what most of us will need of course in
the iphone 7 it will come with a
lightning cable to 3.5 millimeter jack
so you will have that covered if you do
get the new phone well i just want to
give you guys a quick little update
since i was getting a lot of questions
about this so hopefully this was helpful
although it's not that helpful because
they're not out yet so we need solutions
now we need answers now this phone is
going to be here before we know it
and like i said my body is ready and my
body is ready for science so if anybody
if any scientists out there are ready to
implant some bluetooth headsets
or things into my brain mostly if if
apple if apple if you guys want to if
you want to use me for science i'm i'm
available i'm i'm free
just send me an email
send me a tweet
i'll fly out to you guys i'll be there
i'll be there in a second
all right i'll see you guys later happy
tech tuesday peace out
[Music]